[Music]
in 1966 a well-known scientist released
a book with information that could
impact everyone on Earth but before
anyone could read it it was classified
by the CIA we only learned about it a
few years ago when it was Declassified
but the CIA only released 57 pages of
the original
284-page manuscript and those pages have
been in the cia's own words sanitized
now why does the CIA think this book is
so dangerous that they had to hide it
from the public for 60 years and
continue to hide most of it well it's
because the man who wrote it describes
the end of the world
foreign
1966 former McDonnell Douglas engineer
Dr Chan Thomas released a book called
The Adam and Eve story and that title
might sound like he's being cute but
he's actually being literal this book is
about the end of the world as we know it
uh hey what's up is this one of those
stories we are scared the hell out of us
didn't you wrap it up with a happy
ending well you're half right no no if I
soil my bowl again you gotta remember to
edit that out they didn't know you had
an accident you just told them well
Thomas presents evidence of a coming
shift in the Earth's poles that creates
a cataclysm and Thomas says these pole
shifts are cyclical that on regular
intervals a disaster wipes out almost
all human life and we start over again
in the Stone Age he says we're actually
the sixth Advanced civilization to
evolve on Earth there may have been even
more civilizations that have been here
but the further back you go the harder
it is to know for sure because some of
these civilizations occupied continents
that no longer exist now Thomas isn't
the first scientist to publish this
theory in 1958 almost 10 years before
the Adam and Eve story Charles hapgood
published the Earth's shifting crust
which discussed the Earth crustal
displacement hypothesis this Theory says
that sometimes the Earth spins really
fast and the continents are rearranged
when hapkood proposed the idea of
continental drift it was called
pseudoscience but hapgood had his
supporters in fact Albert Einstein wrote
the forwards for two of his books now of
course we know that hapgood was right
the continents do move they drift apart
and collide together over and over again
and have done so for almost 4 billion
years Pangea was the super continent
that broke apart to form the land masses
that exist today but before Pangea there
was a supercontinent gondwana which
existed for 400 million years before
gondwana there was panosia before that
rodinia Colombia Atlantica Arctica
kennerland Ur and valbara these were all
super continents that eventually broke
apart and reformed after working with
Einstein and a few other scientists
Charles hapgood released the book The
Path of the pole as an update to his
previous theories in this book hafgood
suggested that the Earth's poles are
constantly moving again this piece of
pseudoscience was eventually proven true
halfgood believed that a pole shift
between 15 and 40 degrees occurred
around 9600 BC or 11 600 years ago
younger dryas but the peri-reast map is
something that is baffled scientists for
hundreds of years on the peregris map is
the continent of Antarctica but
Antarctica wasn't discovered until 1820
and Perry Reese claimed the information
on his map came from much older Maps if
Charles hathgood was right and the
Earth's axis was shifted 15 degrees from
where it is now Antarctica wouldn't be
completely covered in ice hapgood
believed in Ice Age civilization long
forgotten mapped the coast thousands of
years ago though many have had Good's
theories have proven to be true the Ice
Age pole shift is still controversial we
do know the polls shift over time we
also know the continents drift over a
very long period of time but Dr Chan
Thomas in his book The Adam and Eve
story says the shift happens in less
than a day Chan Thomas describes in
detail what this will be like and it's
worse than any Hollywood disaster movie
ever conceived far worse
Chan Thomas begins his book with a
chapter that describes exactly what
we'll experience during this pole shift
event but before we get into it now
might be a good time to hit pause and
grab fresh underwear I've learned to
listen to him when he says that with a
rumble so low is to be inaudible
infusing into a thundering Roar the
earthquake starts only it's not like any
earthquake in history in California
mountains shake like ferns in a breeze a
mighty Pacific rears back and piles up
into a mountain of seawater more than
two miles high then starts its race
Eastward
the wind attacks shredding everything in
supersonic bombardment the mountain of
Pacific seawater follows the wind
Eastward burying Los Angeles and San
Francisco as if they were but grains of
sand
across the continent the Thousand mile
per hour wind wreaks Unholy dungeons
everywhere mercilessly and here's why
there's such violent wind the Earth
spins about a thousand miles per hour we
don't feel this because everything is
spinning together the land the water the
atmosphere the Thomas says that when the
pole shift happens the earth's air and
water continue to spin but the land
masses stop in many places the Earth's
molten sub layer breaks through and
spreads a sea of white hot liquid fire
in a fraction of a day all vestiges of
civilization are gone and the great
cities Los Angeles San Francisco Chicago
Dallas New York Boston are nothing but
legends barely a stone is left where
Millions walked just a few hours ago now
think of what would happen if you were
in a car going a thousand miles per hour
that suddenly stopped now think of what
would happen if a large city going a
thousand miles per hour suddenly stopped
skyscrapers would collapse millions of
people would be thrown around like they
were in a food processor very few people
would survive that but survivors are the
Unlucky ones because moving across the
country at the speed of sound is a two
mile high wall of water mud and debris
South America finds the Andes not high
enough to stop the violence in less than
a day the entire continent is burned by
molten Earth fire buried under miles of
violent Seas then turned into a frozen
hell everything freezes man Beast plant
and mud in less than four hours when the
shift happens the land on Earth stops
moving so the sun stops moving in the
sky that means one side of the Earth is
going to get really hot and the other
side really cold a temperature drop of
180 degrees that means even the warmest
parts of the planet are going to be 80
degrees below zero everything is frozen
solid within four hours Europe cannot
escape the Alps Pyrenees whirls are
shunken then heaved even higher when the
wall of SeaWorld water strikes western
Africa and the Sands of the Sahara
Danish the fury Marches On for six days
during the sixth day the ocean starts to
settle the Bay of Bengal Basin just east
of India is now at the North Pole the
Pacific Ocean just west of Peru is at
the South Pole new ice caps begin to
form in the new polar areas Greenland
and Antarctica now rotating equatorially
emerge with verdant tropical foliage
Thomas is predicting a 90 degree shift
to the Earth's axis basically turning
the planet on its side the poles moved
to the equator and the equator moves to
the poles New York lies at the bottom of
the Atlantic covered by unbelievable
amounts of mud of San Francisco Los
Angeles Chicago Dallas and Boston not a
traces left the cataclysm has done its
work and drives the pitiful few who
survive into a new stone age We join
Noah Adam and Eve Atlantis Mew and
Olympus and Jesus joins Osiris to Aura
Zeus and Vishnu in the first chapter of
his book Dr Thomas paints a terrifying
future but How likely is it in the next
few chapters Thomas goes on to not only
prove his post shift as possible that
it's happened before and will happen
again very soon in fact there are signs
that it may have already begun
every culture has a flood myth abrahamic
religions have Noah's flood the Mayans
have the hutacon flood where the word
hurricane comes from ancient Hawaiians
have the Newton flood the Sumerians
wrote about a flood in Gilgamesh Europe
Asia Pacific Islanders and native tribes
from All Over America they all talk
about a great flood that cleansed the
Earth so civilization could start again
now one myth is just folklore two myths
are a coincidence 40 flood myths this
starts to look less like a myth and more
like actual history now in this channel
we typically associate great floods with
the end of the last ice age the younger
dryas and core samples provide solid
evidence that this happened but what's
interesting is Thomas said the last
great flood wasn't 11 500 years ago but
6 500 years ago now in the 1960s there
was very little if any proof of this but
a few years ago archaeologists found
evidence of the gunnu flood myth in
China evidence of a great flood has been
found in the Mediterranean and in the
Black Sea these discoveries put the
flood between 6 500 and 7 000 years ago
more recent than the younger dryas and
right when Thomas says it happened Chan
Thomas provides the dates of other
floods the younger dryas is about 11 500
years ago before that a flood 18 500
years ago and this is exactly the time
when the Bering land bridge went
underwater before that 29 000 years ago
which was the end of the Wisconsin
glacial period And before that 43 800
years ago but Global floods aren't
controversial we know they happened what
is controversial is the claim that
advanced civilizations existed before
each of the floods mainstream archeology
and paleontology say the first
civilization emerged in Mesopotamia 6
500 years ago but what if that was just
the last reboot you like the Batman
movies exactly The Dark Knight Rises is
the best one can we discuss Batman later
I'm trying to talk about the end of the
world here well that's why I keep
interrupting coward when we look at the
erosion around the base of the Great
Sphinx we see patterns that were formed
by running water vast amounts of water
moving at tremendous speeds but if this
is water erosion that means the Sphinx
was created before the last flood 6500
years ago which is before the emergence
of the Egyptian civilization
archaeologists hate that idea and they
really hate the idea that the Sphinx was
built over 10 000 years ago but there's
other evidence of a cataclysmic pole
shift specifically of a great mud flood
and a sunken continent do you mean I
mean Atlantis
[Music]
Chan Thomas makes some pretty extreme
claims in the Adam and Eve story
extraordinary claims need extraordinary
evidence in his dialogues Plato famously
introduced the world to Atlantis the
advanced utopian society that was
destroyed in a cataclysm now until
definitive proof of Atlantis is found it
will continue to be considered a
mythical land but that won't and
shouldn't stop people from looking for
it there is a geological feature in
northwest Africa called the reshot
structure also called the eye of the
Sahara it's about the right size and
shape for Atlantis Plato described the
city as concentric rings with a Waterway
flowing out but even among Atlantis
Believers there's debate about whether
this is a man-made structure or a
natural one but what I find fascinating
is near the eye of the Sahara and all
over the planet you'll see large ripples
in the landscape on the ground these
look like Rolling Hills but they're
actually about 50 feet high the size of
a five-story building and they were
caused by water a lot of water this is
one of the craziest things you'll ever
see these ripples repeated ripples in an
area where there's nothing else like it
this is the Fingerprints of the flood
that's what it is wow
the water here Joe that did this the way
to visualize this is to again begin to
think a tsunami hear what you have to
visualize is a tsunami sweeping over the
land that's over a thousand feet deep
and it's sweeping down over this land at
probably two or three hundred million
cubic feet per second which is an
inconceivable amount of water but
Atlantis isn't the only place lost to
this disaster
on the other side of the world we have
another Lost Continent this is called
the land of mu mu is described by
Augustus Les Long John and later by
James churchward both of whom translated
very old texts from the Maya and India
both of these cultures on opposite sides
of the world describe a vast continent
in the Pacific that reached Hawaii in
the north and as far south as Easter
Island and as far west that it almost
reached the islands of Japan James
Bramwell and William Scott Elliott both
proponents of this Theory claim the
continent was destroyed in a cataclysm
11 500 years ago there's that date again
the yanaguni monument off the coast of
Japan is said to be the underwater ruins
of new namadol and Micronesia is
considered to be the southern part of
Mew the site is full of structures made
of enormous logs of volcanic rock nobody
knows who built this or how but their
society was Advanced just recently lidar
Imaging from the air shows that at one
time Nam adal had an artificial irrigate
patient system that could bring fresh
water to Residents all over the area the
eastern part of Mew is Easter Island and
there could be evidence of a cataclysm
there on Easter Island are the moai
statues and you've seen these it's lots
of heads about a thousand actually and
most people don't realize that these
statues have bodies buried deep
underground so there are two options one
whoever built the statues first dug
holes then buried 30 foot tall 80 ton
statues up to their necks then filled in
the holes or two the statues were
completely above ground but at some
point were buried by something and look
at Easter Island it's a tiny island in
the middle of nowhere at one point
twelve thousand people live there where
did they come from mainstream
anthropology says that people from
Polynesia took a canoe out thousands of
miles in the middle of the Pacific and
hope for the best but if the continent
of new was real then they could have
just walked there this could also
explain why Polynesian languages share
similarities to Greek and maybe why on
Easter Island they worshiped a sun god
called which is awfully close to the
Egyptian Sun God Ra and the connections
don't stop there there are similarities
between Greek Egyptian and even Indian
gods as if all these cultures
intermingled or came from a single
Source chantamas lays out some good
evidence for the cyclical cataclysm
Theory but the big questions are how and
when will it happen
well you're not going to like the answer
Dr Chan Thomas lays out a compelling
argument for a coming Global cataclysm
but when well to answer that we have to
understand how it happens in the story
of Adam and Eve Thomas includes a
diagram showing the cross-section of the
earth and a description of the process
the process of a cataclysm is known now
look at the cross-section of the earth
inside the front cover you'll see two
molten layers the orange ones the
important one is the thin molten layer
starting 60 miles down extending 60
miles deeper to 120 miles below the
surface of the Earth the thick deep
molten layers starting 1800 miles down
at the bottom of the mantle and
extending 1300 miles deeper is the
aerocore seismology has proven these two
orange layers to be molted and they are
white hot over 2500 degrees Fahrenheit
Dr Thomas was able to predict seismic
activity all over the world inside the
Earth the electrical and magnetic
structure of the Interior makes the
layers act as if they were near solid as
long as the magnetic and electrical
structure of the earth maintains its
orderliness it keeps rotating on axis in
a normal manner every few thousand years
the magnetic and electrical orderliness
in the shallow molten layer is
disorganized to the extent that the
shallow molten layer is allowed to act
as a free liquid which then serves as a
lubricant for the ice caps to pull the
shell around the Earth's interior so as
to have the ice caps shift about 90
degrees into the torrid Zone when this
event occurs the layer beneath the
earth's crust turns from solid to liquid
then the land masses can slide around
freely and the weight of the ice caps
then Yanks the Earth off axis in one
quarter to one half a day the geographic
poles move to the torrid Zone and all
hell lets loose well that's an
understatement the atmosphere in the
earth's oceans don't shift with the
shell they just keep on rotating west to
east and at the equator that speed is
about 1037 miles per hour so while the
shell shifts with the poles go going to
the Equator the winds and oceans
continue Eastward blowing and flooding
across the Earth at supersonic speeds
inundating continents with water miles
deep destroying everything with which
man has ever dealt including himself
that's a summary of the process oh when
is all this supposed to happen I need
time to get a steel reinforced bull well
Chan Thomas updated his prediction in
1993 and said the shift would happen in
seven years around the year 2000. he
mentioned that Nostradamus and Edgar
Casey made the same prediction yeah but
that's over 20 years ago which means we
do we do
there's a lot more to the Adam and Eve
story but those are the bullet points
and if you want to read the entire book
there are links below so should we Panic
well let's address a few items in the
book and see how they compare with known
science but first let's clear up a few
things I told the story based on what's
In the book and in the Articles and
videos floating around the web the
videos aren't completely accurate first
you'll hear that Chan Thomas is a
made-up name because the subject matter
was so explosive he wrote the book under
a pseudonym well this isn't true Dr Chan
Thomas was a real person Chan is a
nickname his full name was Dr Chauncey
Powers Thomas he was born in Missouri in
1920 and passed away in 1998. he was
married and had children and
grandchildren he was an electrical
engineer and he did work for McDonnell
Douglas he even appeared as a UFO expert
in a documentary in the 90s and he was
on Johnny Carson on April 7 1965 with
Ava Gabor well at no point in this story
did I think we'd end up with Johnny cuss
and an Ava Gabor Dr Thomas wrote A Few
books some about the coming cataclysm he
wrote about ESP UFOs he wrote one book
on how to teach yourself natural
childbirth what what is
what is birth
don't go there and another thing you'll
hear is that the book was originally 284
pages but the CIA only released 57 of
those pages not true nah the original
book was 57 Pages if you look at the
table of contents the conclusion begins
on page 45 and some people will say the
CIA is withholding documents because
pages are missing like page 8 page 18
page 20 and a few others well they're
missing because they're the opposite
sides of title pages in the original
book They're blank and I could show you
this someone has a copy
[Music]
so the CIA document is the whole thing
well within my classify it well that's a
bit of a mystery
what was classified was the book an
interoffice memo with a shopping list
for some tools and car parts and a
folded up article snip from People
magazine well that's pretty random yeah
if I had to guess this document was in
the possession of a caseworker and it
was classified just as a matter of
course in 1966 the year it was
classified Dr Thomas was working at
McDonnell Douglas on UFO and
anti-gravity technology he also worked
as a project engineer at Bell Labs on a
missile guidance system Shan Thomas was
known to be highly intelligent but very
eccentric the classified documents were
probably part of background report or
maybe someone just keeping an eye on him
you'll hear that the book was banned but
it wasn't just this one document was
classified there were copies in
circulation he also published follow-ups
in 1971 and 1993 and neither was
classified as for the content of the
book itself Thomas doesn't provide any
solid evidence he makes a lot of
deductions from old texts some of which
are pretty big leaps and it seems like
he's borrowing ideas from other
catastrophes like hap good Emmanuel
velikovsky and a few others but he's
cherry-picking his favorite Parts
without giving specifics for example his
theory about the ice caps knocking the
Earth off axis well that comes from
hapgood's first book but after working
with Scientists including Albert
Einstein Pat could issued a follow-up
book that explains how he got that wrong
but Dr Thomas he sticks with the story
and the liquid crust bit he talks about
he says the Earth's magnetism and
electricity become disrupted he offers
no evidence or even an explanation of
how it happens just that it does now
there are ice core samples from the
eastern part of Antarctica that show
it's been covered in ice for at least
1.5 million years now granted the
western side of the continent is a
little trickier because it may not have
always been covered in ice but either
way we know for certain it's been down
there for a long time when Chan Thomas
released an expanded version of the book
in 1993 he didn't make any corrections
or provide any new evidence but he did
have chapters on ESP on UFOs and on
angels it doesn't read as scientific at
all in fact it's a hot mess he jumps all
over the place without a cohesive
narrative it feels like he gathered a
bunch of ideas he had over the years and
then threw them into one final book so
two questions was Dr Chan Thomas a
serious researcher no but is there
evidence to support some of his claims
there is
now I don't believe Dr Chauncey Powers
Thomas was a serious researcher whether
he really had ESP or not I'd rather not
get into it but some of the claims he
makes in his book have been proven
possible we know that Global floods have
happened the evidence is everywhere but
these floods specifically from the
younger dryas were not from the oceans
they were from the rapid melting of
glaciers still they were destructive
they really did create tsunamis a
thousand feet high and they really
raised the sea level hundreds of feet he
says the temperature drops so much and
so quickly that everything is instantly
frozen solid it talks about woolly
mammoths being Frozen with buttercups in
their mouths now this is true mammoths
have been discovered that were frozen in
the middle of eating now it takes a long
time to freeze a steak but the flash
freeze a mammoth those conditions would
have to be extreme according to Thomas
seismic activity is one of the reasons
the Earth's axis shifts this is also
true NASA found that the big Indonesian
earthquake in 2004 shifted the North
Pole about 20 five centimeters East and
the Earth's rotation sped up which
decreased the length of a day by 2.7
microseconds in 2010 an earthquake in
Chile did the same thing the Earth's
axis shifted and the day was shortened
again in Japan the following year it
happened again
um is this a concern not really no
earthquakes speed up the earth a little
bit but the moon slows it down things
stay pretty well balanced the shifts
aren't anything to worry about now the
shifting magnetic poles that is a
concern we know the Earth's poles
flip-flop North becomes South and vice
versa and geologically speaking it
happens a lot it's happened hundreds of
times on average the time between shifts
is about 300 000 years but we haven't
shifted in almost 800 000 years so we're
way overdue how do we know it flipped
well because when lava cools it creates
a record of the orientation of past
magnetic fields like a tape recorder
record sound oh that's pretty cool
actually the poles are always moving in
the early 99 90s the North Pole was
drifting about nine miles per year but
that's been steadily increasing in fact
GPS is updated periodically to account
for this but GPS is being updated every
five years then every year and now every
six months the poll is now drifting at
almost 40 miles per year and the Earth's
magnetic field is weakening quickly
these are signs that a shift could be
coming so what then is that the end of
the world well Life Will Go On animals
that navigate using geomagnetism will be
confused but in a generation or two
they'll figure it out animals that don't
use magnetism probably won't notice a
difference the geologic record shows no
major die-offs during pole shifts and
our species has lived through a few
shifts the past three million years and
we're still here
but now but her ancestors didn't have
satellites or GPS or planes a lot of our
technology is gonna go Haywire but code
can be Rewritten and software can be
patched the real danger is in between
the shifts as we approach a pole shift
the Earth's magnetic field gets Tangled
Up and extremely weakened this leaves us
vulnerable to solar activity solar winds
storms coronal mass ejections these are
bad without our magnetic field to
protect us satellites will get fried if
they're not hardened rates of cancer
will increase dramatically and if you
think climate change is a problem now
climate change is not a problem now yeah
it is don't be a sheep either way the
climate will be very unpredictable but
the biggest danger is our power grids
high enough solar activity could knock
out all electricity on Earth for days or
weeks maybe months in some places to say
there will be civil unrest is a huge
understatement when Dr Chan Thomas
released his book The Adam and Eve story
it was dismissed as pseudoscience
but in the 50 or so years since it was
published a lot of his claims can be
proven it would seem that in some cases
the difference between pseudoscience and
real science is just time and if just a
fraction of Dr Thomas's predictions come
true
our time is running out
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor
subscribe share like comment I know I'm
a broken record but that stuff really
helps the channel and like most topics
we cover on this channel today's topic
was recommended by you so if there's a
story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips and
special thanks to our patrons who made
this channel possible Without You
Without You patrons I'd still be waiting
tables at that biker bar in Queens don't
ask if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grab something from the white file store
your support keeps this crazy train
going
[Music]
let's get out of here before he starts
singing until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]